[Music]
I'm buck Ferguson tonight's episode
isn't just about killing white-tailed
deer it's also about family hey buck
I'll go get him make yourself home make
myself at home ready to go kill your
first whitetail deer you know don't this
will be the greatest video we've ever
made
nailed it I can't believe you're on your
first deer call Caroline father's
teaching their sons to hunt as a rite of
passage as old as time I always consider
myself more of a Marriott guy the Sun
when you see your first white-tailed
deer it's gonna look all cute and fluffy
we can honor the deer but we can't love
it this is boy turkey panini
bananas are good pops all the beer one
deer
let's go you know why I love these woods
out here there's nothing to disturb me
amen
three when you find a deer everything
just falls into place the shop he
doesn't take not now you may never
thought you loved hunting away I could
always be in your life why are you
recording this dawn this is part of the
narrative I just feared it might make a
good midpoint crisis or raise the stakes
a security camera dawn
trying to have a moment with my son
right mom and Greg said that could calm
dad called reg dad yeah but only like
five times first time I met my
girlfriend she's like I'm a certified
mechanic a registered nurse no my go
yeah well guess what I got busted truck
in a heart condition
you and me have done things the rule is
going to remember I think it's probably
color most of this stuff from the other
side of the bridge there you want me to
cross the bridge first so I get coverage
of you testing out the bridge before
anybody crosses it because of some safe
exactly don't worry I got
oh Jesus
[Music]